you know this guy Charlemagne the God
that's what they call him I have trouble
I've told you I can't call him what's
his real name Leonard something Leonard
something Leonard McKelvey I guess is
his real name he was on Andrew Schultz
who's a comedian he was on his podcast
and they were playing some clips of
Colin Kaepernick of course you guys know
Colin Kaepernick former NFL player who
went beyond bananas woke he's no longer
in the league and now is basically one
of the leading proponents of wokism
everywhere everything's racist including
his adopted parents his white adopted
parents who adopted this little black
boy he's going off on them these days uh
here are Schultz and uh mcelvey
discussing just that
this is hilarious no no Colin Kaepernick
says he knows his white adoptive parents
loved him but they were very problematic
things that occurred during his
upbringing oh your hair is not
professional oh you look like a little
Thug
I said that to you yeah and those become
spaces where it's like okay how do I
navigate the situation now but it also
is informed why I have my hair long
today the grown-up version of Eve wanted
to go back in time and give young Colin
a lot of hugs and I was really moved and
saddened by the level of self-awareness
oh my God
a parent didn't like their kids haircut
never has happened in history welcome to
being a child and having parents and
that's what your mom's saying to you
right now probably as a black man who
used to be a black boy black teenager uh
when I had an afro and I was getting
cornrows and stuff same thing happened
and I don't have white parents
have a black mom and a black dad who did
not like that especially when I started
wearing Chuck Taylor's and Snoop Dogg
had that murder case well it was made me
especially when I was getting in trouble
in school he made me cut my hair because
for whatever reason me having a big afro
and wanting to get cornrows and wearing
Chuck Taylors equated to me wanting to
be a thug or I'll never be able to get a
good job or anything else like I don't
think that's something that's exclusive
to race yeah but when you see everything
through the lens of racism you're gonna
find it and that's what he sees right
here yeah that's quite right I mean it's
it's an offshooter saying I say all the
time if you if you see everything
through that lens then you'll always
find racism and and what the problem is
then when Real Race racism shows up you
don't even know what to do with it
um I should note that that they they
have that podcast together Charlemagne
the God and uh Schultz that's their
co-podcast I think I said it was uh
Schultz's podcast
um but what's interesting about this
also is that uh Kaepernick is doing
something that I think many uh young
people youngish people are doing and
he's not even that young anymore right
he's got he's got to be in his probably
late 30s at this point uh which is that
you're focused on what you perceive to
have happened to you many many years ago
like if you are an adult if you are
somewhere I'm not even talking about in
your 20s I'll Grant everyone the
weirdness of the 20s once you are in
your 30s let's say if you are still
going man that thing happened to me in
sixth grade in sixth grade I was bullied
by that guy or that teacher wasn't nice
to me or my parents wanted me to pull my
pants up you have a you have an actual
psychological condition that you have to
deal with that you have to actually
confront
[Music]